لا للسرغه نحن ما حرامين احنا سودانيين
يدك على حق غيرك بانه الناس الشعب
السوداني تعب لانه حاصل غلاء في الوطن
السودان فيه غلاه شديد لا في مويه لا في
كهرباء الناس متجهه لبخاع السودان نسبه
الضيق المعيشه في البلد وعدم متوفر الامان
ما شايف شرطي واحد في الشارع لو نزلت
الشرطه امنتوا المواطنين نزلتو البنزين
نزلته كل الناس حترتاح
العنصريه نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط
ونتكلم عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني
محترم لا يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق
غيره نتكلم عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت
في المحنه دي
لا للحرب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات